way to closing broadband gaps ending
homelessness
all this is when you feel the difference
in the day
but the only way to meet these
challenges i believe that we have to
come together as a nation you may
get it you know i've had the feelings of
speaking in
conference and marriage many many times
i've always had enormous respect for
just how trusting jobs are in manchester
so much respect when i first felt like
that i was a councilman
and uh after two years when they
reinforced
me i decided to run for the center it
was too hard because local fish
everybody knows the quality of lives
all on your shoulders you know making
sure people feel safe walking down the
street
making sure the garbage can kicked up
all of those all the concrete things
that could make a great
citizen's day but you know the partners
with these
uh there are parts but but the practical
things and what you have to do
people look to you and that's why i've
made a majority workforce
the first thing i did was to go over
there some of you may remember this
that's how i occur
i spoke with over 200 mayors first
democrats republican independence to get
the stimulus funding
out and invested in the cities all
across the country
it took time to work like hell and made
it money
worked together
because of you our mayors we came
through that crisis
today is not a one-off meeting
it's just a start i approach
administration will have an open door
for mayor our team is
fully failed we heard you heard from
julian
rodriguez
it doesn't matter for all americans
american communities who deserve the
full support
of an american president i promise you
every mayor deserves a president
who is going to be a true partner and
the bottom line is built for the bottom
up
there's nothing beyond our capacity we
just have to come together as a country
and i mean that from the bottom of my
heart i know when i said that when i
announced the president almost 500 some
days ago
i said i wanted to unify the country
well i mean
i hope you as well well thank you all
again
and now i'd like to turn this over to
mayor we look forward to the discussion
all right thank you so much
more divided